[Music]
hello everybody my Oh what you bout to
intrude hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to another
challenge with bro
also known as Rosanna pansino and this
is my diamond play button if you don't
know why this is here you got to go to
the video over on her channel where we
there's another nerdy nummies just like
we did for five nights of red me back
then but they didn't have an award for
that I have this it's amazing you're
gonna close up on that yeah
that's pretty nice thanks anyway that's
gonna be right here so we are reverting
back to our playground days and we're
going to play with some play-doh so the
challenge is we're both going to be
getting a prompt and we have to sculpt
this mysterious thing that we're gonna
be knowing in just a second Mike is
behind the camera he's gonna shout it
say hi yeah so we're gonna be given a
prompt we're gonna get this and then an
impartial judge of three separate people
Molly Tyler Mike they're all gonna be
doing the judging for us and they're
supposedly impartial they're not at all
Tyler even said as much that he was not
going to vote for me before this
challenge started he explicitly stated
that I was not gonna be voted for I did
I explained it what about the food any
beginning oh I'll go judge we're gonna
yeah we're gonna be getting a prop we're
gonna make it out of play-doh it's best
of five we have one minute to make it so
I'm gonna get ready and open not up yeah
yeah keep them closed only I win Nene
one minute what if I can't get Celine
off for like twenty thirty well that's
too bad for you okay looks like I will
be the victor okay okay a cat here's a
body
he's body that's true more legs I like
you have bodies this one's gonna be
stealthy stalking through the jungle
tail
build some jungle that's a tree isn't
that's a tree that's a tree it's it's a
frond of a tree and it's hiding in the
jungle
it's a Bengal tiger ma bro from
Cincinnati here cares about that stuff
we need stripes I'm get I'm already on
the space oh yeah cuz it was the jungle
that did it for you right yes I'm gonna
have to vote mark to because he got the
stripes and half scenery yeah
stripes and scenery really with the
extra mile
okay I want a clean sweep here it's mark
because he was able to the play-doh out
yeah mark thank you that was a
well-deserved win really creative
because I definitely deserve that your
next item is delicious pizza go
italiano word not again not again
really I gotta get some nice pepperoni
on here yeah I think I'm good oh I'd eat
this okay
you gotta get the mozzarella cheese
flake down there okay get a nice and
flaky on there I mean who doesn't like
green peppers on there hey there that's
a delicious looking pizza but I have to
say I'm just gonna pretty it up with
some nice crust going on here
an elegant distribution I'm gotta rest
I've got my I can make a stuffed crust
pizza there we go just gonna stuff that
crust in there after just one bite it's
a surprising sight of stuff gonna be
stuff I'm done I think I can just I
think I'm I'm good I'm confident than
this sausage is good idea I'm a steel
that I guess
oh it fell off on this side feel
pretty good about this weight I mean
they're both good
they're both good what what is this a
double-dip just curious about the orange
crust this
I'm gonna go throws Annika she has
breasts and sauce and I've never had an
orange pizza before
oh my foot is gonna go to Rosana as well
ah come on I put so much detail in wrong
shredded the part of the mozzarella
thank the sauce and the cheese and the
really browned nice shape that that
piece of dough diana stuffed crust the
crust was stuffed one crust was stuffed
when crap I can see him oh this one oh
he's right there
Oh a two-year-old could make that this
takes skill and art it's coz my sausage
fell off isn't it cuz my sausage we're
tied 101 your next one is a spooky
spooky jack-o'-lantern go oh I don't
have enough orange for this woo woo I'm
setting the mood it's spooky
Scott blood red eyes they're so angry
vicious fangs he's even got a little
gangrene in his eyes got an infection ah
[Music]
okay show the judges over here how funny
guys what no it's not I've got mine
figured out aye aye vote mark just
because the color adds a little bit more
pop Thanks wow I'm gonna have to vote
mark to for tough ground activity tough
crowd ambience yeah thank you thank you
you remember the ambiance I'll go with
RO cuz it actually looks like a
jack-o'-lantern
well why didn't my not look like a
jack-o'-lantern I thought for sure he
was actually gonna hollow it out and
make holes
that would have been smart but we are
not that thing I think that's bias bias
is it bias it's two to one make a super
happy snowman go I'm happy looks like a
penis oh that's cheating
ah scar okay it didn't get it it's a
neck brace all right let me explain my
the happy the happiness that comes from
a snowman comes from making the snowman
all the little kids in town had the best
time making the world's biggest yellow
snow they all pitched in F it's the
season of giving and they good stop
giving that's what the arms are made of
I'm gonna have to go with the Snowman
that I personally would wanna build and
that would be Rosie oh come on
Evelyn that's like that that's the
cutthroat kitchen oh I gotta give it a
row oh come on it's not expecting that
it's not to be sure I can select being
like a god
what universe is this duh that you put
in the bathtub you know in the little
floaty duck
talk about this when we get I think for
creativity mark but for following the
directions I gotta give it to RO it's a
happy snowman I pretty much figured I
was gonna lose after had the idea is our
last round and big stakes because with
ties my games tied it shouldn't be tied
I think the audience is in my favor on
this one they're in your favor but you
know that's just the way the cookie
crumbles
you have to make yourself shizzle join
they're the epitome of manliness come on
you know they're okay all right
made myself I have pale skin
um I have pink lips brunette hair and I
tried to get some eyelashes on there and
a few chicken pox scars or actually just
my finger just jammed in there my nail
but I have a triple box car to match
okay all right so mine I chose white
skin because choosing yellow would have
been racist red obviously the hair is
perfect there's nothing wrong with that
ah I have an incredible brown nose just
cuz Who I am
the cheesiest smile yeah okay and then
green eyes I'll go ahead and vote mark
because he has all the features of the
face the network size miss the nose I
think I'll go ro for artistic ability I
would much rather look at that than mark
what man you can't read by artistically
didn't need prerequisites coming into
this did we as a judge I that's what I'm
saying
terrible judge
comes down a Bali bud need I remind that
I can beat you to death with very heavy
very heavy I'm gonna have to go with
force Anna oh it fans we fought next to
her face I never think they're what but
what what mark I I the hairs you this is
garbage 100% grade-a garbage I did not
work my ass off to win this award that I
could be thwarted by biased judges the
funniest part is he thought I was the
one that wasn't gonna be voting for than
us you still didn't you did two of three
times you voted for me wait I'm gonna
make you something what doesn't make you
feel better here we go there's all this
right here goddamn camera I see a little
child so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this video check out the cupcake
video we made over on her channel it's
in the description below thanks again
everyone for watching in let me know who
really won this down in the comments
y'all know they won't be by a sorry 9
word they had more heart they had more
soul and more like integrity I will give
you the uniqueness yeah thank you okay
mystic conscience would not let me vote
for the person or conscience oh those
are like really deep words and I like it
geez hey guys I just got done editing
this video and I just wanted to add on
I'm not actually mad it may seem like
I'm salty but I'm just playing that up
because I thought it was funny there's
really kind of no way that I could have
won this challenge
Rose job is decorating pastries so
Plato's not too far off and I highly
recommend you guys check out the video
that we did for her channel all about
the YouTube play button except for the
new ruby one which I don't think anyone
else besides field is ever gonna get so
thank you everybody so much for watching
just remember Rose a lovely person I
adore her and I love doing these videos
with her so definitely check her channel
out so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye